you might have heard that tesla ceo elon
musk now holds a major stake in twitter
he was set to join the company's board
but then those plans reversed before all
the back and forth he reignited one
request that twitter users have had
since nearly the beginning of the
platform
where is the edit button
musk pulled his followers on twitter to
see if they wanted it and millions
weighed in with nearly 74 voting in
favor of it an edit button might sound
familiar because you're already used to
seeing them on facebook instagram and
linkedin but on twitter it might look a
little different let me catch you up on
why it's complicated for twitter and
give you a brief history on social media
edit buttons i'll also talk about what
the feature might look like on twitter
once it launches and how it might be
different from what you're used to
let's go back in time to when twitter
first launched the year is 2006 and
you're sending tweets out into the world
the same way you send an sms text
message you only have 140 characters to
get your message right text it to this
number but there's nothing you can do to
take those tweets off of other people's
phones if they got the alert via text
message to clean up or clarify what you
meant you'd have to send a new tweet or
delete your tweet from the website but
to be fair twitter wasn't the only
social media company that didn't allow
you to edit facebook also wouldn't let
you change a status after you posted it
regardless of how many typos you made
that is until 2013.
that year facebook started letting users
edit all their posts and comments
and the following year instagram started
letting users retroactively tweak their
captions and you don't really have to
worry too much about people trying to
rewrite history when someone changes the
wording of a post anyone who sees the
post can see what changes were made at
least on facebook and eight years later
on twitter we still don't have an edit
button despite it being the platform's
most requested feature social media
experts told me on twitter things are
slightly more complicated where people
follow politicians and thought leaders
every word and since tweets are public
by default posts on twitter can go viral
a lot more quickly than they might have
on other platforms lots of users see
twitter as a hub of political discourse
and for news and just like in the old
days once you put it out there you can't
go back and change what you said users
see that as a way of holding people and
institutions accountable for what they
post but the ability to edit tweets
would allow tweeters to dial back
language it also allows them to double
down on their message if it starts to go
viral and for a long time twitter did
not want to change just two years ago
twitter's ceo at the time jack dorsey
said that an edit button was unlikely in
twitter's future but it turns out
twitter has been working on an edit
button since last year though not
everyone is excited about the
possibility of an edit button people
against an edit button argue that it
could be used to make more substantial
changes a user could revise a tweet
after it's gone viral completely
altering its meaning and potentially
misleading other users for active users
the news of a potential edit button
could mean a few things visually it
might look something like this mock-up
twitter released
[Music]
also twitter says it's figuring out how
to add parameters so it might work
differently than how it does on facebook
and instagram one idea the company has
is to create time restraints so you
would only be able to edit a post within
a certain window of time twitter could
also add other signifiers showing that a
tweet was changed and it could restrict
the amount of characters you're allowed
to alter the company's head of consumer
product jay sullivan tweeted this
without things like time limits controls
and transparency about what has been
edited edit could be misused to alter
the record of the public conversation
but if you want the tool you'll have to
pay at least at first twitter is beta
testing it in the coming months for
people who sign up for twitter blue it's
a subscription service for 299 a month
that gives you more ways to manage your
twitter account and it'll also let you
customize the app twitter declined to
comment beyond its public tweets if
you're like me and barely tweet an edit
button might not mean so much you may
occasionally run into someone trying to
abuse the new feature by tweeting
something obnoxious to drive up their
engagement and then changing it to
something more mild i mean it is social
media after all but at least you'll be
able to keep misspelled words from
lingering around on your profile for all
of eternity
you